hi there steve kaufman here
today i want to talk about
our language goals and re-evaluating our
language goals i'm going to do that
because i am re-evaluating some of my
goals in this
nine-month you know extreme language
learning project
and i had another i had a few sort of
interactions which again confirmed to me
the need to every so often reevaluate
what we're doing
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe i talk about language
learning sometimes i speak in other
languages
uh and of course if you like the video
give me a like apparently that's good
for me
good for my ratings and all that stuff
uh but
i don't i really don't care uh so
reevaluating my goals first thing that
happened is that i i began to realize
that you know i'm working on three
languages arabic persian and turkish and
really that's too much i can't
concentrate one of my motivations was
that if i left you know when i was doing
three months of one and three months say
three months of arabic three months of
persian three months of turkish by the
time i got back to arabic i had slipped
too much so i said well i kind of it's
like having three pots on the burner if
i kind of keep them all simmering
then i won't fall too far behind in any
one of them
but i'm finding that you know the
challenge of arabic and persian the
challenge of learning to read in a
different writing system
but it's the same writing system arabic
and persian slightly different
now that's sufficient there's a lot of
work to be done there
and that the turkish actually is a lot
easier the language itself is difficult
different at any rate
but it's written in the latin alphabet
so it's kind of easier in a way so that
if i go back to turkish in nine months i
don't think i'll lose that much i think
i can get back to it pretty quickly i am
motivated to do turkish but i'm also
motivated to achieve more progress in
arabic and persian so i have to make a
choice so i've decided
i'm going to focus on arabic and persian
same writing system get better and
better at reading
that
script which will in turn make me a
better reader make it easier for me to
acquire vocabulary so i have decided to
focus on those two
languages i mentioned that i am in touch
with uh people in in persian that are
creating stories about themselves
uh we've now got 10 in a course at link
called the iranians
uh unfortunately not unfortunately but
it's mostly women i'd like to have more
male voices there just to have a better
balance but there are very interesting
short descriptions of ordinary people
ordinary iranians you know
iran kind of is getting pretty bad press
these days but it's important to realize
that those are individual people who
live there who aren't very different in
terms of their aspirations and what they
want to do and how they interact with
their family members and so forth in
most cases not very different from
the way people in other countries are so
the iranians as a course enables me to
learn about the language and learn about
people
and i'm also continuing to you know use
news podcasts similarly in
uh arabic and i'm beginning to feel as
i'm understanding more and more of it
more and more of the words are known to
me more and more when i listen i
understand
uh which is you know a a great feeling
that feeling that you're starting to
make some
some significant you know uh uh
improvement and so if i leave turkish
and put it aside i don't think that's
gonna be a problem so i'm focusing
completely focusing now on arabic and
persian so that's where i stand on
reevaluating my objectives i was also
i noticed that uh luca lamporiella who
is an excellent lamborghini excellent
polyglot recently did a video where he
says that he has decided to stop his
japanese efforts for now he said it was
a failure i don't think it's a failure
i'm sure he speaks japanese quite well
but not as well as he would like and so
he has decided for whatever reason to
set that aside and do something else and
i'm sure that if something were to come
along that would very much motivate him
then he would jump back into his
japanese studies and he would do very
well because he has he is a very
experienced language learner
i was talking to someone from japan
yesterday uh a video that you will see
here shortly
and i was exp and i was asked what my
advice to
sort of language learners in japan was
and i sort of said you know
that the language learning is such a
rewarding activity but we have to do it
in a way that's enjoyable because that
way we stay with it and if we stay with
it we will
improve and she said yeah but
unfortunately in japan people have to
pass tests so that becomes their focus
and i said yeah but if they really
evaluate their objectives they will
realize that in order to do well on
those exams you have to enjoy the
process so you have to find a way to
enjoy it and so
doing you know trying to learn from
lists of words or doing all these drills
and exercises or mock tests moctoic
tests etc actually is not getting you
closer to your objective if you really
looked at what your objective was i mean
you want to improve in the language if
you have a toeic score and then
maybe you can somehow ace the test
without knowing the language which i
doubt
then if you are in working for a company
where you have to go and interact with
people from foreign countries you won't
do very well so ultimately the real goal
is to get you know to improve your level
in the language if you improve your
level in the language then you will do
well on the tests and then you'll be
effective using the language and so
really the goal should be
as i've often said with language
instruction as well how do we make it
enjoyable how do we make it enjoyable
because if it is enjoyable people will
stay with it now
my turkish was enjoyable but i had too
much on my plate it's like if you go to
a
restaurant and you want to try
everything on the menu but you can't eat
everything on the menu so you have to
make a choice so
that's why
right now i have decided that my 90 day
not
nine months rather challenge extreme
language learning where i was going to
do three languages
i have finally decided i mean i may
occasionally look at turkish
just so it doesn't get too far away from
me but i'm gonna focus my energies on
arabic and persian so i have reevaluated
my objectives and i'm focusing in on two
languages which is still a tall order
and i hope to be building up our library
at link as i go so i
anyway you'll see we'll have more and
more material there for
arabic and persian
okay that's what i wanted to say and if
you want to uh take my uh
get uh subscribe to my 10 email course
on how to learn languages uh make sure
you click through on the link that's
here on the screen thank you bye for now